nous poursuivons pour l'instant avec un
tout autre sujet cette nouvelle campagne
de communication du département des
yvelines le lancement a eu lieu cette
semaine un film institutionnel pour le
moins décalé un acteur a été recruté
pour mise en scène inattendue le film
sera diffusé notamment dans les salles
de cinéma de la région mais aussi au
delà jusqu'à la défense notamment afin
de faire découvrir les yvelines et
surtout de faire comprendre aux
touristes et aux investisseurs que les
activités ne manquent pas en dehors du
mondialement reconnue château de
versailles une campagne d'affichage est
aussi lancée simultanément vous pourrez
les découvrir notamment sur les quais de
la gare montparnasse regarder en
attendant l'extrait le teaser de cette
nouvelle campagne vidéo du département
les yvelines ses musées son patrimoine
son histoire
ah oui ce n'est pas que ça les yvelines
regardez si tout ça les yvelines comment
s'est déroulé le tournage justement et
puis les explications sur cette nouvelle
campagne promotionnelle c'est au micro
de nos confrères dix mille et une
première vous savez le département des
yvelines impacte l'ensemble de daisy
vinoy au quotidien dans ses compétences
le matin vous déposez vos enfants à la
crèche
c'est une compétence du département des
yvelines vous les emmenez ensuite au
collège c'est une compétence du
département des yvelines
il déjeune dans une cantine scolaire
c'est une compétence du département des
yvelines
l'après-midi sur des structures
sportives multifonctions par exemple un
synthétique c'est le département des
yvelines
etc etc jusqu'au soir où lorsque vous
allez voir par exemple un de vos proches
en résidence pour personnes âgées
c'est une compétence du conseil
départemental des yvelines alors nous
avons voulu dans un ton décalé que l'on
doit à jean louis barcelo n'a qu' un
acteur que vous connaissez bien et bien
donner un peu d'oxygène à sion et
interpeller le public et le grand public
j'explore de fond en comble les yvelines
je fais de la montgolfière je fais plein
de trucs et on découvre les yvelines
d'une manière complètement différente en
fait je fais la montgolfière j'ai eu
très très peur sur montgolfière j'ai
fait de la boxe je me suis pris oignon 1
brignon sur l'oeil droit et là j on va
peut-être arrêter sinon on va pas
continuer le tournage